Wir haben schon einige Länder kennen gelernt, wie zum Beispiel Burkina Faso. Um nur eins zu nennen, um nur eins zu nennen, um nur eins zu nennen. Wir brauchen so einen Rhythmus. Namibia, Uganda, Tansania, Äthiopien, Sambia, Ruanda, Burkina Faso. So, oder? Oder kam erst Rom, nee, Rom kam erst. Namibia und Uganda, Tansania, Äthiopien, Sambia nagelt mich nicht auf fest, Ruanda, Burkina Faso, Senegal. Senegal, wow. Wow, vielen Dank. Und damit ein herrliches, herzliches Ho-Ho-Ho zu dieser Weihnachtsfolge. It's a wild Christmas. Ja, wir wollten aber auch noch mal die Gelegenheit nutzen, um auf das Jahr zurückzugucken, und da hat natürlich Afrika bei uns eine große Rolle gespielt. Deswegen sehr, sehr passend. Vielen Dank an Simon für den Antenne-Afrika-Rap. Sehr, sehr grossartig, und ich glaube, wir haben viel dazu beigetragen, der Welt Afrika näher beizubringen. Ich glaube, wir haben es weiter weggerückt ein bisschen. Und jetzt liegt es an anderen Podcasts, es wieder ein bisschen herzuholen.
Ja, wir äugeln da auf Antenne Askaban, Antenne Alderaan, da vielleicht mal wieder ein bisschen ranzuziehen.
Aber wir haben, glaube ich, mehr für Entfremdung gesorgt dieses Jahr.
Und wir konnten tatsächlich auch den Heuschreckenschwarm nicht aufhalten.
Es ist uns nicht gelungen, es ist leider nicht gelungen.
Nee, aber rückblickend wäre es vielleicht besser gewesen, bei Antenne Alderaan Antenne Afrika zu machen, wo man wirklich gar nicht damit rechnet. Ja. Also wo wirklich, wo dann einfach Star Wars-Content, Star Wars-Content, Afrika, Afrika, Afrika. Jede zweite Folge ist einfach zehn Minuten Afrika-Content, wäre vielleicht die Wurstentscheidung gewesen. Hier geht es ein bisschen unter, in diesem, ist auch ein lauter Podcast, viele laute Themen. Viele Stimmen, die durcheinander schreien und sperrig sind und akustisch sehr sperrig, also schwer irgendwie einzuordnen, deswegen, ja, kann schon sein, dass es untergeht, vielleicht brauchen wir eine neue Rubrik irgendwie, weil wie gesagt, wir haben jetzt noch 50 Folgen vor uns, das ist noch eine Menge, vielleicht können wir doch noch Antenne Amerika oder Antenne, weiß ich nicht, irgendwann nochmal reinholen. Jetzt gerade könnte ich, glaube ich, jeden Bundesstaat auch zählen. Sage ich, grosskotzig, und dann fallen mir drei ein. Aber das war nicht, jetzt mit der Wahl bin ich, glaube ich, noch sehr gut gewappnet. Ja, für die nächste Wahl dann vielleicht. Oder falls mal wieder Wahl ist in Antenne Benelux oder so, können wir auch mal machen. Antenne Benelux. Oder Welle Benelux oder irgendwie sowas. Ja. Müssen wir mal gucken. Wir gucken, wir gucken mal. Ich habe zu viel gegessen, glaube ich. Und zwar habe ich rückwirkend mal nachgedacht, dass sich bei mir die Mahlzeiten immer mehr konzentrieren. Also ein klassisches Fünf-Mahlzeiten-Programm, irgendwie Frühstück, Mittagessen, Vormittagessen, Nachmittagessen, Vesper, Vor-Nachmittagssnack Lunch, Vesper meinst du das kleine Rollerchen, wo du rumfährst. Dann Dinner und dann noch mal ein Mitternachtssnack. Habe ich immer mehr zusammengedrückt und teilweise esse ich wirklich nur noch einmal am Tag, aber dann halt wirklich so eine Maurice-Ravelle-Mahlzeit, wo wirklich einfach alles viel zu viel. Für mich macht Essen ausserhalb des Exzess keinen Sinn mehr.
Wenn ich esse, dann will ich so viel essen, bis ich wirklich sterbe.
So gerade eben geschehen.
Ich habe mir, glaube ich, zweieinhalb Kilo Nudeln reingeballert,
kann mich kaum noch bewegen.
Deswegen ist es ganz gut, dass wir jetzt einen Podcast machen,
damit ich einen Vorwand habe, mich eine Stunde lang nicht zu bewegen.
Aber machen wir uns jetzt vor, bei mir führt auch dieses Intervallfasten dazu,
dass ich einfach mittags mehr esse, als als den ganzen Tag über sonst gegessen hätte. Ja, und ich bin ja auch dumm, also zum Beispiel dieses klassische Nudelfänomen, müssen wir nicht darauf eingehen, wurde schon ausgiebig besprochen in der deutschen Podcastkultur, dieses man macht immer mehr Nudeln, als man braucht, aber ich habe einen Weg gefunden, das noch zu überhöhen, dieses Problem, indem ich mittlerweile Nudelsorten mische. Also wenn du jetzt sagst, oh, Penne-Varbenne, hole ich mir heute zum Mittag, sage ich Non und sage, nee, wir machen Penne und dann kippe ich aber noch Fusilli mit rein. Also es ist wirklich wie so. Ohne ganze Pizza nach oben drauf und dann ist das nicht mehr gegessen. Es ist ein bisschen wie Nudelsalat eigentlich, so du hast verschiedene Nudelsorten durchgemacht. Ist Nudeln nicht auch Salat, weil da werden wir bei der alten Frage, wie viele Zutaten brauchst du zum Salat? Frage ist, wie viele gesunde Zutaten brauchst du für den Salat? Und ist ein Nudel nicht einfach immer Salat? Eigentlich schon, es ist das Salat und die Sauce ist das Dressing. Im Grunde ist es eigentlich Salat. Und dann habe ich das aber so ganz perfekt getimt, also das ist wirklich die Choreografie, weil manche Nudeln brauchen acht Minuten, manche sieben Minuten und dann habe ich noch die Minipenne, die brauchen fünf Minuten und dann ist es immer so, ich werfe erst die rein, warte 60 Sekunden, dann kommen die nächsten, warte eine Minute, dann kommen die nächsten. Du machst nur Nudeln warm, fühlst dich aber wie Thomas Keller persönlich oder so, Anthony Boudin, weil du denkst, weil du musst drei Zeiten im Blick haben. Ich habe immer so ein Handtuch über die Schulter geworfen, ich habe immer so einen probier-kleinen Teelöffel in der Brusttasche drin, fühle mich dann gut und probiere dann das Nudelwasser. Brauchst du nicht mehr? Nee. Das finde ich immer so toll, wenn man Köchen zuguckt, da haben die immer so eine Handvoll kleine Teelöffel, so eine Handvoll, dann wird sie in die Mitte gelegt, alle nehmen sich ein. Genau, alle nehmen sich ein. Jetzt kriegen wir diese rauen Mengen an Teelöffel. So eine Handvoll. Alle nehmen sich ein.
Und ich denke mir, diese rauen Mengen an Teelöffel,
die braucht man ja eigentlich.
Hat man immer zu wenig. Jede Küche,
auch oft in Firmen usw. Zu wenig Tassen,
zu wenig Teelöffel. Jedes grösste Missverständnis der Erwachsenenwelt
ist, dass, wenn du zum Ikea gehst und dir
Besteck kaufst, jedes Besteck gleich
oft vertreten ist. Das ist die grösste
Lüge der Menschheit. Niemand kann das leisten. Man müsste von Anfang an sagen, Messer brauche ich so drei, Gabeln vier, grosse Löffel zwanzig, kleine Löffel sechzig. Das ist so wirklich das Verhältnis, das ich brauche. Glaubst du, man muss mal einfach die zu Unrecht genormten Dinge in Frage stellen und mal einfach durch Ikea laufen und sagen, Abnormen, pass auf, wir brauchen eine neue Abnorm. Abnormen, wir normen mal ab kurz. Man kann aufrunden, man kann abrunden. Man kann aufleiten, man kann ableiten. Gut. Podcast entwickelt sich nur noch zur Aufzählung von Wörtern. Wir könnten jetzt sagen, ableiten, umleiten, aufleiten, durchleiten. Wäre alles möglich. Wäre alles möglich gewesen. Habe ich aber nicht gesagt. Ich habe nicht alles aufgezählt. Auch diese Dien-Normen, oder? Ja. Können wir da mal darüber nachdenken? Das verstehe ich auch nicht, warum die so krumme Zahlen haben. Weil wir sind im Zeitalter von Instagram. Warum nicht einfach sagen, alles wird quadratisch? Es ist viel einfacher, alle Rücksacke werden quadratisch, alle Blätter werden quadratisch. Oh, aber Kino wäre nicht so schön. Kino quadratisch hat man sich ja wegentwickelt von, aber man entwickelt sich auch gerade wieder zurück, das stimmt schon, weil IMAX ist ja jetzt wieder, das war mir gar nicht so klar, aber entwickelt sich ja weg von Cinemascope wieder hin zu quasi 16 zu 9. Ja, vielleicht könnte man dann aber auch einfach beim Kino sagen, okay, statt Breitbild hat man dann halt zwei Quadrate.
Eins neben dem anderen. Aber es ist immer noch so ein bisschen Abstand dazwischen. Genauso wie wenn man irgendwie potthässliche Bilder hat und denkt, okay, wie kann ich die ein bisschen kultiger aufhängen, dann hängt man die so mit leichtem Abstand nebeneinander ab, aber es ist immer noch ein Motiv und man denkt sich einfach, da kann ich aus einem potthässlichen Motiv was künstlerische Ansprechendes machen,
wenn ich es einfach in drei Teile teile.
Weil jeder weiß, drei Teile teilen, künstlerisch genial.
Picasso kann man das Wort Triptychon aufgeschnappt.
Richtig, allein weil das Wort Triptychon so sophisticated klingt
und intellektuell.
Otherworldly quasi.
Und dann, das ist lustig, meine Tante, die hat, liebe Grüße an meine Tante, die mir immer bei jeder Geschichte sagt, erzählst bitte nicht im Podcast. Aber es ist Weihnachten, fuck it. Ich werfe mit Geschichten um. Die hat, was sehr lustig ist, hat auch zu dem klassischen Urlaubsbild Triptychon im Wohnzimmer gegriffen. Urlaubsbilder kann man ja schön mittlerweile, keine Ahnung, bei White Wall oder Poster, ich klicke es älter oder sowas, kann man die dann zu so Acrylbildern machen. Und dann haben die sich überlegt, wir machen Triptychon aus dem Death Valley. Schönes Fotomontiv, kennt man auch, diese schönen roten, glatten Felsen, die man auf der Amerika-Reise immer mitnimmt, irgendwie so ein bisschen Grand Canyon-artig. Halt drei Fotos, und dann haben die drei, wollte ich einen Triptych anmachen, haben das aufgehangen, alle fanden super, Nachbarn waren begeistert, Familie Hellauf, in heller Aufruhr, bis ich herausstellte, dass einem aufgefallen ist, dass eins, das rechte Bild, exakt das linke ist, nur einmal gedreht. Aber gespiegelt oder ... Nein, einfach auf dem Kopf. Und ich glaube, es ist sogar beim Aufhängen, es wollte sich ja nicht zugeben, aber schon aufgefallen, weil man es dann gleich aufhängt und man sah einfach das gleiche Bild. Und dann wieder umgedreht und dann sieht es halt wie ein leicht anderer Fels aus. Wenn man genau hinguckt, ist einfach das gleiche Bild auf dem Kopf, was ich eigentlich clever finde. Finde ich auch konsequent, ja. Weil so Triptychon, fuck it. Ja, das wäre dann wieder konsequent. Beim dritten ist ja auch egal. Es kommt ja dann auf das Triptychon an, nicht auf jedes einzelne Bild. Ja, ja. Das fände ich aber wieder konsequent, wenn man einfach dreimal desselben Motiv macht. Dann wird es zu Popart wieder. Wenn du einfach sagst, du machst immer wieder dasselbe Motiv, dann wird es wieder cool. Dann wird es Andy Warhol-mäßig. Ja, das fände ich wieder gut. Ja, finde ich ganz gut. Aber ansonsten ist das einfach so hoffnungslos, dann aus hässlichen Bildern noch was Gutes zu machen. Aber gut, ich bin auch nicht für so Fotos. Selbstgemachte Fotos. Ich habe, glaube ich, schon erzählt, ich habe wieder ein Poster gekauft, viel zu klein. Ich dachte, es sei Postergrösse, aber es war DIN A4, viel zu klein. Weißt du, wo ich das hinhängen soll? Lustigerweise, es zieht sich auch durch bei meinem Chef, dem Philipp, unserem Produzenten von der Serie und mir und dir jetzt offensichtlich auch, dass wir Kunst oder halt andere Gegenstände oder sowas kaufen in falschen Grössen. Weil wir alle offensichtlich zu dumm sind, auf die Masse zu achten oder uns Masse nicht sagen. Ich habe ja das Bild gehabt, viel, viel, viel zu groß. Dann hat er sich ein Bild gekauft, aber bei der gleichen Website viel zu gross, nachdem er mich wochenlang fertig gemacht hat, dafür, dass ich mir ein viel zu grosses Bild da gekauft habe, weil er meinte, du kannst auf die Maassen gucken. Und ich konnte ihm das Phänomen nicht erklären, bis es ihm auch passiert ist, er sei ein viel zu grosses Bild und jetzt hat er sich so Salz und Pfeffersteuer gekauft, die unglaublich klein sind. Die sind so klein, die sind so winzig, wenn man die neben das Bild stellt, dann denkt man an so einem Phantasialand-artigen Haus, dann kommt man an einem Spiegel vorbei, wo man ganz dick ist. So ein Funhaus, so ein verrücktes Labyrinth. Es stimmt schon, wenn du dann sagst, okay, jetzt ziehen wir es durch, jetzt kaufen wir alles klein, ab einem gewissen Punkt passt es wieder, weil alles wieder das gleiche Verhältnis hat. Es darf halt nur nicht manches zu gross und manches zu klein sein, dann wird es absolut absurd. Ja genau, wir wollten nochmal den Sketch machen mit Bernhard Hohecker in einer Wohnung, wo alles ein bisschen zu klein ist, wo er ganz normal gross aussieht. Und als Antwort kam doch, kann man jetzt mal erzählen, so aus Kleines hinter den Kulissen, Bernhard Hohecker macht generell bei nichts mit, wo sich aber seine Grösse lustig gemacht wird. Oh. Dann haben wir ihm einen Glatzen-Sketch angeboten. Dann haben wir ihm einen Glatzen-Sketch angeboten. Bernhard Holiker kam dann nur dieses Augenrollemodie zurück. Seitdem haben wir nie wieder was von ihm gehört, tatsächlich. Nee, ist vielleicht verstorben. Man weiß es nicht. Ich würde auch sagen, wenn ich versterbe, möchte ich, dass das erst drei Jahre später bekannt gegeben wird.
Ich erwische mich manchmal mittlerweile bei Drehbüchern, dass manchmal sind Actionzeilen einfach nur noch ein Emoji. Okay, Moritz so und dann halt der Große mit den grossen Augen, der so rot wird, der Erschrockene. Ja, und einmal habe ich dann am Set auch gesagt, Maxi, spiel mal so wie dieser Smiley mit den Zähnen, der sich so ertappt fühlt. Und tatsächlich hat er dann in etwa das gespielt, was ich cool fand. Ja, perfekt. Und man denkt so, das ist ja was ganz anderes. Man muss ja nicht mehr mit Wörtern beschreiben, was man will vom Schauspiel. Man kann ja einfach Emoji so den Default-Menschen, die Default-Emotion sagen. Ich fände aber auch gut, wenn du so einen grossen Ordner dabei hättest, mit so ganz vielen Bildern von dir selbst, wie du verschiedene Gesichtsausdrücke machst und dann sagst, einmal die neun bitte und dann hältst du deinen Ordner hoch, wo du so das war prallig. Ne, doch über neun b, danke. Einfach so einen, guck mal so wie ich damals. Am Anfang kriegen alle so einen grossen Ordner, eine Ordnersammlung von mir.
Ja, im Grunde filmt man dann ja auch nur die einzelnen Emotionen ab und schneidet es dann im Schnitt zusammen, wie es passt.
Ich weiß ja, wie ihr Hollywood Freaks das macht.
Ja, wie Hollywood Freaks.
So, da ist ja keine Immersion da, du kannst hier nicht den Charakter einfinden.
Du bist ja eigentlich wie so eine Buchdruckmaschine.
Gib mir einmal jeden Buchstaben und dann füge ich das im Nachhinein, das Wort zusammen, das ich haben will.
Ja. Mit dem, hä, hm, ah, und dann kannst du es genau in der neuen Formel zusammenstellen. Wo hat man N gesagt, da hat ein N gesagt. Ich denke mir, es dauert auch nicht mehr lange und das war nicht ganz im Ernst, das ist die große, kann man ja auch mal zum Ende des Jahres machen. Du haust immer Sachen raus, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Ich weiss noch nicht genau was, deswegen finde ich der Satz schwer. Und ich bin mir aber ziemlich sicher, dass es schon etwas ist, das es schon seit sieben Jahren gibt. Und wir auch schon mal gesagt haben in diesem Monat. Nee, halt Deepfake, basically, will ich jetzt sagen. Ja, das ist ja Brandpär. Ich will jetzt Deepfake-Vorhersagen. Dass es schon Deepfake-Vorhersagen ist immer gut. Hat Nostradamus bestimmt auch gemacht, aber ging halt, weil es damals nicht so gut dokumentiert war alles. Ja. Wäre einfach gut belesen. Nee, aber dass man tatsächlich dann einfach bei Adobe Premiere oder so eingibt, was der Schauspieler sagen soll, und dann kann er das sagen. Und das geht noch nicht so gut, aber es wäre schon ganz geil, weil ich meine, es gibt ja diese ganzen lustigen Instagram-Filter, wo irgendwie alle jetzt in dem, wo quasi Taylor's Wolf dann plötzlich dein Gesicht hat und singt und so. Ich denke, das ist doch nicht mehr weit entfernt davon, dass man einfach keine Schauspieler mehr braucht, sondern mal einmal einen Schauspieler 3D scannt und sagt, Dankeschön, kannst du nach Hause gehen. Ja, aber das ist dann schwierig. Wer kriegt dann Geld und kann man dann machen damit, was man will? Was ist, wenn der stirbt und nicht mehr zusagen kann? Alles schwierige Fragen, die alle besprechen werden. Man kauft dann einmal die Rechte an denen. Und du gibst dann komplett deine Rechte ab an deinem Bild und bist dann irgendwie auf so einem Hund oder so, hast du dann irgendwie Matthew McConaughey auf einem Hundekörper in irgendeiner lustigen Familienkomödie oder was. Vielleicht spielt Brendan Fraser dann plötzlich einen sehr guten Film die ganze Zeit mit, weil alle mögen ihn ja tendenziell, aber Karriere war eigentlich schwierig. Ja. Der hat auch eine Trichterbrust übrigens, also. Stefan hat gerade den offiziellen Trichterbrust groß gemacht, hat sich einmal selbst auf die Brust geküsst, das war erstaunlich mit anzusetzen, wie er das schafft. Aber solche Leute wie du, ihr könnt das. Früher wäre ich in so einem Zirkus vorgeführt worden, so einem Freakshow-Zirkus. Ja, aber nicht wegen deiner Brust. Ja, ansonsten war ein tolles Jahr, viel passiert. Wollen wir mal die Pufo Weihnachten vorschlagen, so Filmtipps oder unsere Weihnachtsrituale und dann sollen die mal alle nachmachen zu Hause? Ja, ich schau Herr der Ringe. Der Herr der Ringe. Du schaust der Herr der Ringe? Ich schau der Herr der Ringe. Das ist wie wenn man sagt, Ring der Nibelungen, aber es sind nur Ring des Nibelungen. Du musst auch seit der sagen, der Herr der Ringe.
Ja, da schaue ich mir an und grieße das. Schön mit Making-of-Material, guck mir alles an. Aber da kommst du ja nicht über die ganze Weihnachtszeit. Doch, maximal bis zum ersten Weihnachtsfeiertag. Doch, die dauern ja neun Stunden und dann hast du noch das ganze Making-of und so. Ich gucke mir das alles an, so wie die da die Schwerter geschmiedet haben und da mit den Sachen reingefahren. Und es ist echt auch verrückt, da gibt es ein cooles Video auf YouTube zum Thema rausgeschnittenes Szenen aus Heiderringe. Verrückte Sachen, die man sich heute nicht vorstellen kann, wie Eowyn in den Höhlen von Helmsklamm kämpft gegen Uruk-Kai, wie Arwen bei Helmsklamm mitkämpft, Aragorn kämpft gegen Sauron. Meine Augen werden immer kleiner, weil ich immer angestrengter nachdenken muss, wer noch mal wer ist. Ganz klein sind die jetzt schon. Ganz, ganz wilde Szenen. Ja, stimmt. Und ganz spannend, ist ja oft so, dass wenn man den Film kennt, wie er ist, dann so rausgeschnittene Szenen wirken wie, also das hätte ja nie im Film sein können. Aber genau so gut hätte es drin sein können. Und viele andere Szenen akzeptiert man nur, weil die einfach im Originalfilm drin sind. Genau, auch lustig die Star Wars Episode 5, die Lidscenes, und jetzt kommen, glaube ich, bald von der vier, also von A New Hope, kommen bald, glaube ich, die Lidscenes raus, wo ich mich sehr darauf freue. Das ist auch schon erschienen, muss ich mal nachgucken. Megacool. Aber das ist wirklich geil, und Episode 5 ist wirklich ganz, ganz seltsam. Ganz urkomische Dialoge zwischen Leia und Han, also grauenhafte so Romanze bei denen in so einem hotelartigen Zimmer in of Hoth oder Bespin oder so. Auf jeden Fall ganz weird. Lohnt sich immer mal reinzugucken. Aber das stimmt schon. Vielleicht wären die normal gewesen, aber ich glaube nicht. Ich glaube, das wäre ein schlechterer Film, wenn die drin wäre. Das macht ja auch einen guten Regisseur dann aus, zu wissen, was gehört rein, was gehört nicht rein.
Und bist du dann trotzdem noch, wie muss man sich denn dich vorstellen auf dem Sofa, Hedringel, guckend?
Nee, immer schön auf dem Bauch liegend, der Prall mit Lebkuchen gefüllt ist.
Die Beine wackeln sich hin und her.
Genau, stehen so 90 Grad nach oben und kreuzen sich dann immer abwechselnd eine vorne, eine hinten hin und her.
Niemals hat das jemand umständlicher beschrieben.
Ihr müsst euch mich unbedingt ungefähr so 50 Zentimeter erhöht vorstellen. Wo? Weil mein Bauch voller Lebkuchen gepresst ist. Und Weihnachten wird es auch immer wie so eine Maschine, mit der man so ein Auto anheben kann, wie so ein Wagenheber. Giesige Gabelstapler, ja. Prinzipiell bist du dann irgendwann ganz an der Decke. Genau. Immer weiter hoch und dann starre ich auf ein winziges Display, das verdreckt ist von meinem Laptop und schaue mir schön Herr der Ringe an und ziehe mir das rein. Aber auch flüssig? Nein. Nee, stockend, stockend, 240p, schön von Kino X, schön gestreamt und die besten Bedingungen für den perfekten Weihnachtsabend eigentlich. Dann, ich bin ja auch mal auf der Suche nach neuen Weihnachtstraditionen, letztes Jahr habe ich ich John Mulaney and the Sack Lunch Bunch geschaut, wo es ein Song ... Das hat man dreimal ganz schnell ineinander. John Mulaney and the Sack Lunch Bunch, John Mulaney and the Sack Lunch Bunch, John Mulaney and the Sack Lunch Bunch. Jetzt auch endlich für alle, die mitgeschrieben haben und es sich angucken können. Es ist ein tolles Musical mit Kindern und da hat es einer der Songs tatsächlich zu meinem Song 2020 geschafft, Im Spotify-Rückblick, was ein bisschen unangenehm ist eigentlich, weil ich aktiv versucht habe, auch nachts immer so Beethoven durchlaufen zu lassen. Stumm. Stumm, damit ich dieses Mal irgendwie einen coolen Rückblick habe. Aber nein, ich habe immer noch Atomic Kitten, einen Song von einem kleinen Kind und Britney Spears mit drin. Und ich kriege das nicht raus. Ich weiß nicht, was da los ist. Und du wirst glaube ich schon vom Verfassungsschutz ein bisschen beobachtet, weil es so pädophil aussieht. Ja, absolut. Ich versuche immer so, gegen November geht dann die Zeit los, wo ich versuche, so vernünftige Sachen zu hören. Erwachsenenmusik. Erwachsenenmusik zu hören, irgendwie nochmal, Jazz mag ich ja immer ganz gern und dann lässt es halt so ein paar Stunden im Endlosschleife durchlaufen. Es funktioniert immer nicht. Du findest einen Song gut und dann sagt Spotify, hier hast du nur noch Songs von Kindern gesungen,
weil du liebst ja Songs von Kindern gesungen.
Und man läuft schon so rot an und denkt,
nein, du kennst mich nicht.
Und dann gefällt dir doch einer davon.
Und dann denkt man, na fuck, vielleicht hat's recht.
Vielleicht hat der Algorithmus recht.
Und ich liebe Kinderstimmen.
Ja, und das ist jetzt vielleicht eine neue Weihnachtskradition, die ich mit
aufnehmen werde in meinem Repertoire und jetzt jedes Jahr John Mulaney in the Sack Lunch Bunch angucken würde. Mit Jake Gyllenhaal, ganz tolle Leute. Wer noch? Lustig, lustig. Sehen wir noch zwei auf. Nee, jetzt mal, um mal nur einen zu nennen, Jake Gyllenhaal. Um nur einen zu nennen. Um nur einen zu nennen! Und ja, macht Spaß. Wie schaust es bei dir aus? Du sitzt in deiner Wohnung, die überhin. Quatsch, ich möchte ein paar, also ich habe vor allem Lust, jedes Jahr folgende Filme zu gucken. Einer meiner absolut lieblich Filme, Inside Llewyn Davis von den Coen Brothers, den finde ich ganz toll. Der kriegt mich mit so einer winterlichen Stimmung, schneit auch viel in dem Film, wird viel gesungen, das gefällt mir sehr gut, packt für mich Weihnachten ganz gut, ist ein bisschen melancholisch, also muss man, wenn man jetzt irgendwie Bock hat auf ein Upper, eher nichts für euch. Gehört aber auch dazu, mal so in den fallenden Schnee starren und mal so ein bisschen melancholisch in sich gehen, warum nicht? Und dann Fago natürlich, also der Film Fago, ganz, ganz toller Film, auch meine Liebesfilme, den unbedingt gucken.
Alle mit Schnee, alle Filme mit Schnee. Alle Filme mit Schnee, das wäre mir wichtig. Dann habe ich ein Guilty Pleasure, und das ist Van Helsing. Oh, wow, damit habe ich jetzt nicht gerechnet. Ich gucke jedes Jahr zu Weihnachten Van Helsing. Ich finde den ganz toll. Ich weiß nicht warum. Es ist ja, ob ich nicht ein toller Film, auch unglaublich schlecht gealtert. Ist es der Hut? Es ist ein bisschen der Hut. Ich glaube, es ist der Hut. Der macht viel mit einem. Es ist der Hut, es ist die Armbrust. Ja. Du hast meine Armbrust, würde er bei der Ringe sagen. Und du hast meinen Hut. Du hast meinen Bogen und meine Axt. Und er hat schön, der ist Vampirjäger, ne? Der ist Vampirjäger, es ist im Prinzip die Dracula-Geschichte, auch gar nicht so weit weg von der originalen Dracula-Geschichte, nur so ein bisschen übernatürlich. Ich mag den sehr gerne. Ich mag die Stimmung, ich mag die Musik von Alan Silvestri, ist irgendwie cool. Ich mag Transsilvanien auch. Ja, ist ein Sehnsuchtsort, ne? Ist ein Seurtsort für mich. Transsilvanien, wir haben nicht nur Vampire. Wir haben nicht nur Vampire, wir haben auch Berge. Sieben Berge, sieben Gebirge. Ja, es ist ein guter Film für mich zum Gucken. Ich weiß nicht, warum. Kommt man da wahrscheinlich nicht gut rein. Wenn ich den jetzt angucken würde, würde ich wahrscheinlich nicht die Dinge da sehen, die du drin siehst. Nee. Dann Independence Day habe ich jetzt schon wieder geguckt, der habe ich schon hinter mir gebracht. Ganz, ganz, ganz fantastischer Film. Den finde ich wirklich auch unironisch super. Den finde ich richtig klasse. Ich habe zu Weihnachten so ein paar einfach so ein paar Gildy Pleasures, die vielleicht keine guten Filme sind, aber die man irgendwie dann gerne nochmal guckt. Independence Day finde ich einen richtig, richtig guten Film. Der fängt so toll an und der hat so einen Drive die ganze Zeit. Unglaublich patriotisch. Und eigentlich muss es einen damals auch verwandt nicht verwundert haben, dass es ein Deutscher gemacht hat. Das ist so der patriotischste Ami-Film eigentlich, von Roland Emmerich halt. Ja. Aber naja. Der hat wahrscheinlich sich gedacht, was mögen Amerikaner. Das vielleicht? Das vielleicht. Ja, genau das. Dann natürlich Harry Potter, die ganzen Harry Potters. Alle. Nochmal einmal durch. Du hältst es bis nach fünf durch. Ich glaube, ich skipp ein paar. Ja, nee, nee, es gibt die letzten vier. Ich finde sieben Punkt eins fantastisch. Da hat man richtig viel Zeit mit Hermine und Ron. Nee, aber die wird es in der Schule haben, nicht da irgendwie Camping oder so. Das ist so. Stimmt, das ist ein bisschen wie so ein Holiday Special. Ja, es ist wie so Schulfreunde, wo du denkst, wir haben uns in der Schulzeit so gut verstanden. Und dann fährt man irgendwie in Urlaub und denkt sich, nee, ich mochte die nur, wenn die wirklich neben mir in Bio saßen und man irgendwie gekichert hat zusammen. Aber jetzt irgendwie auf so einem Tandem in Sizilien ist die Magie weg. Und so war es bei mir bei Harry Potter auch. Das ist wortwörtlich die Magie weg. Es ist die Magie, da wird weniger gezaubert, da geht es dann nicht um Schulnoten und so. Mir gefällt mir nicht aber gut, wenn du da einen Spaß dran hast. Das ist ein bisschen so wie bei High School Musical 2, wo man sich entschieden hat, das ist nicht mehr in der High School. Wir spielen in den Ferien und man sitzt davor als Fan und denkt, was, das glaube ich nicht.
Aber angenommen, du machst dann auch mal so Rewatches, sitzt du dann mit grossen Augen und richtig angespannt, ohne Handy in der Nähe, vorm Bildschirm und guckst das? Und bei jedem Jumpscare bist du noch gleich aufgeregt? Ja, doch, das ist bei Herr der Ringe schon. Bei manchen anderen Filmen lasse ich auch mal laufen, gucke dann oft dann so auf IMDB die Trivia durch, irgendwie, lese mir das durch und mal so ein bisschen Hintergrund zum Filmen mache ich immer ganz gern und dann driftet man ab und dann ist man ja irgendwie da woanders und dann aber Herr der Ringe gucke ich mir immer an. Und bist du noch gleich aufgeregt? Ganz viele Details, es sind so viele Details immer im Hintergrund und ich habe ja auch immer das Herr der Ringe Sammelkartenspiel gespielt, wo dann die Karten immer so einzelne Frames aus dem Film hatten. Das heißt, ich kann dann auch immer sagen, ah, die Karte hatte ich, die Karte, Karte, Karte hatte ich alle und ah, hier Gumbling und den und das hatte ich alles. War das ein Daumenkino im Prinzip? Im Grunde ist ein Film ein Daumenkino, ja, das ist korrekt. Ist eigentlich ein Trading-Kart-Spiel, das einmal vor dir auf dem Boden fällt, ist eigentlich ein ganzer Film. Im Grunde hast du das. Ja, und Tenet ist wirklich dann einfach auch, da ist man da immer drüber gelaufen und ist ein bisschen durcheinander gerutscht alles. Ach nee, ich will diesen Film nie wieder sehen, ich will ihn vergessen. Das war wirklich die grösste Irritation dieses Jahr, war dieser Film. Okay, grösste Irritation 2020 war für dich Tenet. Ja, bis jetzt nicht verstanden, ich glaube, der kommt auch bald auf iTunes, aber ich werde ihn mir nicht nochmal angucken. Das ist so dieses Buch, das du dreimal angefangen hast, aber du checkst es einfach nicht, es ist zu hoch für dich
und irgendwann wirst du wütend, weil das führt dir
deine eigene Unzulänglichkeit vor Augen und
du sagst dir, nein, weg,
ich bin dir nicht gewachsen und das ist
für mich Tenet. Trotzdem, in jedem Smalltalk
führt man es erneut an, natürlich
verschweigt man den Fakt, dass man nicht verstanden
hat und so hofft, dass man
durchkommt, einigermassen und hofft, dass man man jemanden vor sich, der sagt, ich mache den Film nicht. Ja, aber das ist eigentlich ganz gut, weil bei Tenet kannst du dir hundertprozentig sicher sein, dass die andere Seite es auch nicht verstanden hat. Genau. Und bei manchen Filmen gibt es ja wirklich so Leute, die haben da wirklich was dazu zu sagen. Zu Tenet hat niemand was zu sagen, weil alle sich nur so rumdrucksen und sagen, ja, tolle Kameraeinstellungen, tolles Pacing, wirklich tolles Coming-of-Age-Drama, richtig gut und sich manchmal ein bisschen verheddern. Oh, wir haben übrigens eine Anfrage zum Thema der App Bullshit. Hat sich tatsächlich jemand gemeldet, der Bock hätte, die zu programmieren? Es bräuchte dann nur noch Input aus der Community, das heißt, wir müssen dann einmal einen großen Aufruf machen, wer kennt sich mit Opern aus, wer kennt sich mit deutscher Literatur aus und dann einfach so. Ganz bei beiden hätte ich gesagt, ja. Und dann fällt Fakt mit drei Fragen. Ja, wer kennt sich mit Biologie aus, Chemie, Physik. Ich mach das. Ja, genau, da brauchen wir dann Hilfe aus der Community und dann gebt ihr uns so ein paar Stichworte und dann kommt ihr mittlerweile mit dieser neuen App Bullshit durch jede Konversation durch, weil sie euch ein paar Schlagwerter gibt. Das ist ja immer noch wichtig, dass wir die nicht gute Branden. Jede App, das Podcast-Ufo heisst. Das ist die vierte App, die wir rausbringen und jede heißt das Podcast-Ufo. Das ist wirklich verwirrend. Nee, das trägt halt zur Markenbildung bei. Ich weiß nicht, ob das zur Markenbildung beiträgt, wenn die Leute es hassen. Vielleicht sollten wir unsere Apps gerade Gästerlister Geisterbahn nennen, dass wenn es irgendwie auf dem letzten Platz der iTunes-Charts ist, die Leute sagen, nee, das habe ich schon erwartet so. Dann können wir unseren Namen nicht ruinieren. Eine Freundin von mir hat erzählt, dass sie Weihnachten immer gleich verbringen, quasi, es wird jetzt in die Kirche gegangen, dann kommt man nach Hause, dann war das Christkind da, ist ja auch eine spannende Diskussion, wer war da, Christkind.
Möchtest du die Anführungszeichen erwähnen, die Stefan um Christkind gesetzt hat? Ich glaube, ich finde es schwierig, weil Christkind ist so, im Kindergarten hat man mir immer gesagt Weihnachtsmann, zu Hause wird einem gesagt Christkind, so what's up man, I'm getting mixed sick.
Einigt euch, ist es ein Team, sind es mehrere Leute? Sind es die Power Ranger? Dann auch immer die eine Tante, die immer gesagt hat, ich habe es gekauft, das Christkind hat mir gesagt, was du dir gewünscht hast. Genau, ich habe es gekauft, dann habe ich es dem Christkind gegeben. Ich habe es dem Christkind gesagt und es hat es dir besorgt. Wo hat es das besorgt? War das Christkind im Laden? War das Christkind bei Toys R Us? Ich weiß es nicht. Das wäre eigentlich auch so ein Chat, oder? So eine Telegram-Gruppe von so Achtjährigen, die so eine Verschwörungstheorie bilden, dass es das Christkind nicht gibt. Und dann so Verschwörungstheorie-Videos machen mit so Bildern von so verschwommenen Schemen, von wem ist das Christkind. Und ich habe mein Geschenk zur gleichen Zeit bekommen wie du, wie kann das sein? Das fände ich unglaublich lustig. Können wir diesen Sketch an irgendeiner Late-Night-Show verkaufen? Unser Verschwörungstheoretiker-Kongress, wo die dann alle kommen und alle durchdrehen. Das wäre unglaublich lustig. Wir machen eine Telegram- Verschwörungstheorie-Gruppe, wo Achtjährige... Stimmt, wir machen die Gruppe auf und alle spielen Roleplay, als wären sie Kinder, die denken, das Christkind gäbe es nicht. Das können wir wirklich machen. Ja, lass uns das machen. Finde ich super. Wir machen Roleplay, um halt der Gesellschaft satirisch vorzuhalten, wie es denn läuft mit Verschwörungstheorien und dass diese Gruppen für den Arten... Dann schön die Christkinddiktatur und irgendwie, ja, da kannst du da deine gesetzte Schlagwörter machen. Ja, Deep State, Deep Christmas quasi. Ja, Deep Christmas. Und eigentlich hat das Christkind auch nur einen Kinderporno-Ring. Im Keller von ja, was auch immer. Weihnachtsmann? Von den Elfen? Nordpol. Die Elfen ist auch nur synonym für Kinder. Keller. Aber es ist ja genial, dass es jemand geschafft hat, wie Coca-Cola
den Mannesmann zu etablieren,
einfach so aus Scheiß, so eine kulturelle
Doch, doch, das stimmt schon.
Und als kulturelles Phänomen tatsächlich bis heute
gefestigt haben konnte.
Man verbindet es heute halt nicht mehr.
Man hätte halt den vielleicht eher den, also folgte Idee,
aber den vielleicht irgendwie den Coca-Cola-Mann
nennen können und dann als
Sinnbild für Weihnachten, weil dann würde er
Werbung machen, weil der ist ja mittlerweile...
Oder einfach das Podcast-Dofo.
Lass es da
noch mal drüber reden. Aber
momentan macht er ja keine
Werbung für Weihnachtsmann, der ist ja Rogue unterwegs,
der ist ja ein Outlaw.
Der hat sich jetzt zurückgezogen in die Antarktis.
Pepsi, der
Weihnachtsmann.
Und jetzt sagt Pepsi, dass sie den Weihnachtsmann, jetzt haben die irgendwie so einen Weihnachtshasen oder sowas, so ein Hybrid zwischen Osthasen und Hansen. Haben die auch Rudolf erfunden, da kommt ja ganz woanders her. Das ist irgendwie so ein Franchise, wo ein bisschen zu viele Leute mitgeschrieben haben. Ja, auch das mit diesen Elfen und mit dem Kamin, ich glaube, da kommt einiges zusammen, das ist eh so eine Mischung aus allem, möglichst. Ja, weil Rudolf ist ja auch ein anderes Franchise, aber plötzlich spielt Rudolf aber auch im Weihnachtsmann-Franchise, nicht im Christkind-Franchise. Dann gibt es den Nikolaus. Manche sagen auch, der Nikolaus kommt, aber der kommt auch an Nikolaus. Ja, aber manche sagen, der Nikolaus kommt. Nikolaus, das ist noch ein anderer, der Nikolaus. Da sind zwei Brüder, der Nikolaus und der Nikolaus. Nicolaus. Und die könnten sich nicht anders nennen? Nein. Das ist auch alles bescheuert, ey. Aber naja, gut. Müssen wir durch. Deswegen eine kleine Empfehlung für mich, für Leute, die auch ein bisschen was lernen wollen zur Weihnachtszeit. Oh, da muss er sich räuspern, aber jetzt kommt was Wichtiges. Jetzt kommt der Wikipedia-Artikel der Woche, och, och, och, och, und zwar Weihnachten, ich weiß nicht genau, wie der Wikipedia-Artikel lautet, aber das findet ihr schon, Weihnachten in Zeiten des Nationalsozialismus. Ach so, ich war 1862, aber komm, dann mach du weiter. Ne, ganz, ganz spannender Artikel, weil damals versucht wurde, das komplette Fest umzukrempeln mit neuen Bräuchen, mit neuen Ideen, weil die wollten ja so ein bisschen weg von diesem christlich konnotierten Weihnachten und haben sich dann total auf dieses Sonnenwend fokussiert, weil das ja zur ähnlichen Zeit ist, die Tage werden wieder länger, Sonnenwendfest und dann gab es den Statt des Weihnachtsmanns, gab es den Sonnenwendmann und da gab es dann die Lieder wurden umgedichtet und so, das ist total verrückt, das zu lesen. Oh Sonnenwende, oh Sonnenwende, es wird jetzt wieder heller, die Tage lang die Augen klein. Ein rechter Arm geht in die Höhe. Aber genau so saßen die damals da in einem Writer's Room. Auch das wäre ein Sketch, Writer's Room, neues Weihnachtslied, irgendwie mit Anspielungen drin und ist auf jeden Fall faszinierend. Und da habe ich auch gelernt, dass der Adventskranz, den gab es schon immer, aber der hing hauptsächlich, also mit den vier Kerzen und so, der hing hauptsächlich in Kirchen und öffentlichen Plätzen und so, aber erst mit den Nazis wurde der in die Haushalte eingeführt.
Also die Tradition, dass jeder zu Hause einen Weihnachtskranz hat, ist zurückzuführen auf die Nazizeit, wo das natürlich als Sonnenkranz dann wieder verkauft wurde, aber diese Idee mit den vier Kräften, der Sonnenbaum, ja. Bringt der Sonnenwendenmanne dann Geschenke auch oder was? Ja, doch, der bringt Geschenke auch so, aber halt dann muss er ja, weil sonst kauft man das Geschichte. Und es ist auch ein ganz interessanter Teilaspekt Spielzeug im Nationalsozialismus, irgendwie, dass dann immer mehr zu Waffen wurde und so für die Jungs und so. Auch ganz spannend auf jeden Fall, aber das ist ganz interessant, dass etwas, das wir selbstverständlich machen, daherkommt. Das hat jetzt Inhalt nichts damit zu tun und den Weihnachtskranz gab es eben davor auch schon. Aber finde ich ganz spannend, dass die einzige Idee, die hängen geblieben ist von diesem ganzen riesigen Konstrukt, ist die Idee, dass man sich einen Weihnachtskranz zu Hause hinstellt. Hast du Weihnachtsdeko bei dir zu Hause, nein, oder? Null. Kein bisschen. Null. Ich auch nicht. Ich frage mich aber manchmal, ob das nicht einfach auch zugehört. Oder ob man einfach da auf diesem... Also so alt bin ich noch nicht, habe ich das Gefühl. Ich bin noch nicht alt genug für Weihnachtsdeko. Vielleicht so als Bildschirmschoner oder so als Bildschirmhintergrund. Ja, dass dann so Flöckchen kommen. So ein Rentier, so einen biologischen Querschnitt durch ein Rentier. Ja, weihnachtlich, aber man lernt auch was. Sonnenwenden man? Ja gut, das ist natürlich schwierig. Oder einfach so eine strahlende Sonne, die immer ein bisschen zu hell ist. Das ist so dumm, weil niemand will in dieser muckeligen Weihnachtszeit, wo es schön dunkel und gemütlich ist, niemand will sich da mit Sonnen beschäftigen. Ja, natürlich technisch gesehen ist es Sonnenwende und die Tage werden wieder länger, aber das ist halt am falschesten Moment. Das ist so Wissenschaftler, Werner von Braun hat sich da ein bisschen verrannt. Ja, das ist halt der falsche Timing überhaupt. Also sorry, man kann ja viel kritisieren, aber da muss ich echt sagen, nee. Das war das Schlimmste, was die Nazis sich jemals überlegt haben. Die dümmste Idee, die jemals hatten, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Aber toller Artikel, lest sie mal durch, kann man viel auch lernen. Jedenfalls hat die Seite von denen erzählt, dass man dann halt alle, weil das ein sehr christlicher Haushalt ist, haben alle das Gotteslob in der Hand. Kennst du das Gotteslob? Das ist das kleinste Buch mit den meisten Seiten der Welt und deswegen sind das die dünnsten Seiten der Welt. Was man in der Kirche als Katholiker hatte, hatte man das Gottesgub. Du kommst doch aus dem katholischen. Es stimmt so, ich erinnere mich an die unglaublich dünnen Seiten, ja. Ja, das sind die dünnsten Seiten der Welt.
Und in der Kirche war es für mich ja immer einen grossen Spaß, wenn dann der Pfarrer dann irgendwas angestimmt hat schon und die Orgel spielt schon wieder die ersten drei Akkorde.
Und dann oben wurde dann so eine Nummer eingeblendet, so göttlich.
Ja.
Wo kommt die her, wo kommt die her? Aber alle müssen beten, dann kommt die Zahl oben, wird dann anprojiziert und dann ist das die Seitenteil des Gotteslobes und dann muss man im Gotteslob durch diese ganzen dünnen Seiten ganz schnell durchbleiben, um diese Seite zunen, bevor der Song vorbei ist, was immer eine große Herausforderung ist.
Und ich habe immer gegen meinen Vater so Wettrennen gespielt, wer zuerst auf der
richtigen Seite im Gotteslob ist.
Und die haben zu Hause alle
ein Gotteslob und dann wird erst mal die Weihnachtsgeschichte
verlesen.
Einer darf die Daniels ja verlesen
und danach wird schön
gesungen. Alle mit
zuigen Augen und grossen Mündern wird dann erst mal schön Odo Fröhliche gesungen, alle 19 Strophen und O Tannenbaum und hast du nicht gesehen und danach war das Christkind dann da. Sehr schön, das ist bei euch auch so zu Hause. Warum nicht? Wir singen tatsächlich auch noch, das ist das einzige, was übrig geblieben ist, so ein bisschen. Aber spielt noch jemand ein Instrument dazu? Nee, nee, das musste ich viel zu lange machen, Gitarre, bis ich mich geweigert habe, dann da so rumgeklimpert und ich schaue mir auch jedes Jahr so ein Bild an, das ich als Kind gemalt habe mit einem Tannenbaum und es ist fast, es ist eigentlich fast moderne Kunst, dieses Bild, weil es einfach so, hast du es dabei, mein Handy ist weg, achso, Stefan, ne, ich hab das nicht. Du schaust dir immer diese Zaubershows an, so Darren Brown und so. Ich liebe das. Ich weiß nicht, was... Und es ist hinter deinem Ohr. Magic for Humans könnt ihr euch auch gut angucken, tolles, ähm, tolle Serie auf Netflix zum Thema Magie. Dann ist es nichts für mich. Wer mag Magie denn nicht? Jeder liebt Magie. Humans lieben Magie. Magic for Humans, ja. Finde ich auch gut, dass man das nochmal spezifiziert. Ansonsten kann es da zu Missverständnissen führen. Ist ein guter Titel eigentlich. Sind wir auch ein Podcast for Humans? Podcast for Humans. Mostly for Humans. Specific Group of Human Beings. Das sind wir. Ja, Podcast for Human Beings. Okay, also du hast immer ein Bild gemalt. Nee, du hast ein Bild gemalt, und das schaffst du dir jedes Weihnachten an. Da schaff ich mir jedes Weihnachten an, weil es mich mit Freude erfüllt und dir die richtige Stimmung bringt. Was hast du denn da gemalt? Du suchst es gerade auf deinem Handy. Da, er hat es gefreut. Oh, du mir angucken? Oh, das ist wirklich Andy Warhol. Oh, Tannenbaum, Tannenbaum, Tannenbaum und es verschiebt sich immer ein bisschen. Also, du kannst es mal erklären, ich habe ein... Also, es ist ein... Das ist wirklich ein fantastisches Bild. Man erkennt ganz, ganz grob einen Tannenbaum, damit gemeint ist eher ein grosser grüner Klecks. Man erkennt aber ein bisschen so Abzweigungen. Oben natürlich der Stern auf dem Baum, deswegen erkennt man ein bisschen, dass es ein Tannenbaum, lila Kugeln, okay, so weit so gut, da ringsum rotes Flammenmeer, ein rotes, wirklich rote Flammen, sieht auch ein bisschen aus wie so eine Actionkunst. Ja, absolut, klar. Im Moment, da musst du was raus. Du hast dein Innerstes nach außen gekennst. Der ganze Wut meines siebenjährigen Lebens musste in dieses Bild fließen. Und dann steht ganz oben ein O, dann Tannenbau, in der nächsten Zeile M, O Tannenbaum, immer verschoben. Ja, ich wollte O Tannenbaum schreiben, aber die Zeile war zu kurz, so dass dann das M in die nächste Zeile gesprungen ist und es ab dann Motannenbau, Motannenbau, Motannenbau heißt. Aber was ich schade finde, ist, dass es nicht durchzieht, dass es dann zumindest immer um einen verrückt. Nein, es bleibt Motannenbaum, Motannenbau, Motannenbau, Motannenbau. Ja. Und er steht in jeder Zeile wie ein Verrückter. Eigentlich sieht es aus wie eine Gefängniszelle von einem Verrückten, wo man dann in die Gefängniszelle geht und man sieht erst das Gesicht desjenigen, der reingeht und spannende Musik und dann sieht man die Gefängniszelle und dann ist man mit Wachsmalschriften Motannebau geschrieben. Und dieses gesamte Bild, ich habe dieses Otanbaum über das gesamte Bild geschrieben, nicht einfach so als Überschrift, sondern über das gesamte Bild drüber, mit dichtem Text Motannenbau, Motannenbau, Motannenbau geschrieben. Da hat man schon gesehen, dass du ein bisschen Querdenker bist. Ja, oder dass ich einfach nicht gut in die Zukunft plane, einfach dass ich Otannenbau, oh fuck. Keine Voraussicht, fuck, fuck. fuck. Kennt jeder. Aber ich denke mir schon, bei Happy immer,
the birthday is by weitem. Ja, vergiss es.
Vergiss es. Happy, dann birthday,
schreibst ruhig kleiner und du schreibst es immer noch
nicht klein genug. Und dann die Kurve,
die Curve of Shame,
gegen Zeilenende. Ja, aber es ist doch ein I drin,
das sind doch quasi keinen Raum weg.
Gut, das R kommt dann und das B,
dicke, biggest Buchstaben. Ja, riesige
Buchstaben, viel zu gross. Viel, viel, viel zu gross. Aber das schaue ich mir immer gerne an, einfach um so ein bisschen auch wieder auf den Boden zu kommen und zu sagen, du kannst nicht alles, aber es muss auch nicht sein. Manchmal entstehen aus Federn wunderschöne neue Dinge. Weißt du, was ich jetzt dachte? Hier ist die ganze Zeit Mails, dass von den ganzen Kulturstätten und so, Opernhäuser, wo man mal irgendwann in den Newsletter gelandet ist.
Auch nur für das gute Gewissen.
Wo ich mich nur angemeldet habe, um kultiviert zu wirken, weil man ab und zu eine Newsletter-Mail bekommt und denkt, ach.
Also während man gerade mit jemandem anderen so ein Video anguckt, wo ein Hund irgendwie eine Rutsche runterfällt.
Auf die Wiener Staatsoper schreibt.
Genau, poppt die Mail auf die Wiener Staatsoper.
Herr Tietze und jetzt, oh, Entschuldigung.
Schiebt mich so weg.
Pardon. Nee, pardon, ich will gleich den Hund sehen. Zeig mir das, den Infanten und den Hund. Genau, und deswegen dachte ich mir, was dieses Jahr, glaube ich, alle Kulturschleppen versäumt haben, ist folgendes, und das finde ich richtig cool, ein Live-Theaterstück bei Zoom zum Beispiel oder Skype. Wir alle können uns reinschalten und dann quasi gucken wir, müssen uns aber alle stumm schalten, sonst wird man halt gekickt, alle schalten sich stumm und Kameras aus und von so, weiß ich nicht, vier Leute, ein Freundeskreis, bleiben die Kameras an und Mikro an. Und das sind Schauspieler, die uns ein Theaterstück aufführen. Aber auch vor dem Laptop sitzen. Aber auch vor dem gleichen Laptop sitzen. Und es ist quasi ein Live-Film, also ein Live-Theaterstück. Ach, die sind zusammen? Die sind, nee, nee. Die sind auch alle im Haufen. Die sind auch alle anders. Und es spielt halt einfach, es ist halt so ein Film, was war das denn hinter dir? War das der Mörder? Und dann kommt halt, keine Ahnung, dann müssen die den Fall lösen und versuchen vielleicht, keine Ahnung, ist das ein Krimi oder was, oder die reden, oder wir gucken eine Romanze zu und dann merkt man, zwei haben eine Affäre und dann kommt die richtige Freundin dazu, keine Ahnung. Aber warum gibt es das nicht? Das finde ich doch fantastisch. Oder ein Tatort wird auch geil. So ein Live-Tatort. So ein Live-Tatort bei Zoom. Aber ist das eher so eine Lesung dann einfach, oder? Meinst du, oder spielen die das dann wirklich aus und drehen sich um? Die spielen das aus. Es ist wirklich, es ist ein komplettes Theaterstück, nur wir können live dabei sein, es ist bei Zoom. Ein Theaterstück, was bei Zoom ausreicht. Aber die Figuren sind auch bei Zoom oder nicht? Wie die Figuren. Also spielst du dann den Kommissar, der im Zoom-Meeting ist? Ja, ah ja, okay. Genau. Der Kommissar callt nach Hause, Weihnachten, mit seiner Familie. Callt den Verdächtigen. Callt den Verdächtigen. Der geht nicht ran. Fuck. Fuck. So, was jetzt? Abspann. Lass uns seinen Instagram-Account checken. Wir sehen seinen Bildschirm. Genau. Ah, er war an dem Tag des Mordes, hat er kein Bild gepostet. Am nächsten Tag hat er ein Bild gepostet, oh, was war das für eine lange Nacht. Merkwürdig. Markieren, Copy, Paste in meinem Dokument. Und die Hälfte haben den Scroll verlassen. Zuschauer weg. Wo ist eigentlich meine Kollegin? Die wollte eigentlich um elf da sein. Call. Und dann hat man so, Alfred 56 aus Duisburg hat sich hinzugeschaltet, hat vergessen, das Mikrofon auszumachen. Okay, können wir vielleicht ganz kurz mal Wann geht denn die Scheiße hier? Ach, hat schon begonnen. Und dann sofort schlag er dich aus und hat einen Cut, weil er entdeckt hat, das Mikrofon war noch an. Ja, nee, ist eine gute Idee. Ich kann mir das gut vorstellen. Ja? Ja, auf jeden Fall gut. Auch einer ist Chips die ganze Zeit. Die Stirn abgeschnitten von einem die ganze Zeit. Dann Verbindungen weg vom Hauptkommissar und die anderen schweißtreibend wissen nicht mehr, wie sie weitermachen sollen. Impro ist am Ende, Kommissar hat Verbindung verloren. Geht nicht in Deutschland, weil kein gutes Netz. Aber da gibt es glaube ich auch schon so Filme, die da irgendwie eine kommt nicht mehr online und das ist ein Horrorfilm und dann werden die alle nach und nach getötet, glaube ich. Genau, ich glaube auch ein Final Fantasy, nein, wie heissen die nochmal? Paranormal Activity spielt da, nur am Laptop.
Paranormal Fantasy.
Paranormal Fantasies.
Ja.
Drei Szenen.
Ja, keine schlechte Idee.
Vielleicht, ich meine, die ganzen Filme, die jetzt rauskommen, werden alle in irgendeiner Weise Zoom beinhalten.
Wird spannend, das zu sehen, wie das dann... Keine Kussszenen mehr? Nee. Ja, eine Massenszenen mehr, keine Kussszenen. Das wird schwierig. Halt viel CGI, Schlümpfe oder so, kannst du da noch machen? Also drei Menschen und ganz viele Schlümpfe, um Massenszenen darzustellen. Also Leute, die offensichtlich am anderen Ort sind. So wie diese Szenen, diese Force Visions, die Rey und Kylo haben, in Star Wars 8, eigentlich perfekt. Ja, perfekt. So der Gegenschnitt ist ganz woanders, Strand, Miami Beach, Gegenschnitt, Köln in Fußgängerzone, die reden miteinander und dem Film ist es scheißegal, dass sie gerade nicht an einem Ort sein können. Obwohl sie ja manchmal auch im selben Raum sind, aber dann eigentlich nicht wirklich. Naja. Aber um zu signalisieren, dass die miteinander reden. Finde ich, aber finde ich toll. Finde ich auch super. Finde ich richtig gut. Also, was heilt 2021 denn für uns bereit? Ja. Wir hatten ja mal, wir hatten ja mal eine Prognose gemacht, und wir hatten ein bisschen Recht. Ich erinnere mich noch an eine Prognose, Joko und Klaas werden keine Rolle mehr spielen, und es stimmt ein bisschen. Ja, aber keine Rolle, ich meine, die machen jetzt immer diese ganzen politischen Videos. Das haben wir ja für vorletztes Jahr ja meine Prognose für 2020 war ja, es wird mal wieder so einen richtig schönen Serienmörder geben. So einen richtigen, so das ganze Land sucht danach. Ich würde sagen, ich lag falsch. Einfach weil ich nicht viel Zeit hatte. Weil nicht viel aus dem Haus gekommen bin, aber das war auf jeden Fall schwierig. Scheissjahr für Serienmörder, alle drin, in ihren sicheren Buden, nervig. Ja, wirklich nervig und ansonsten, ja, 2021, keine Ahnung, mal vielleicht wieder so einen richtig, so einen spektakulären Weltrekordversuch, irgendwie so die grösste Sachertorte Wiens, so, sowas in der Richtung. Mal zu sagen. So hoffentlich geht sie bis nach Hamburg, hoffentlich geht sie wieder. Ist sie so hoch, dass ich sie aus meiner Wohnung sehen kann zumindest? Sowas in der Richtung, glaube ich. Und da, keine Ahnung, die Sachertorte stürzt um, begräbt vier Touristen unter sich, die sich dann heldenhaft rausessen aus der Torte, die sie droht zu ersticken. Und dann kriegen die einen Preis. Und sowas in der Richtung. Bemannte Mars-Missionen cool. Ach ja, aber ist das utopisch. 2021 hat da wirklich... Tesla wird gekauft von Apple. Oder andersrum. Apple wird gekauft von Tesla, okay.
Das kann man da reinschneiden.
Können wir noch im Edit ändern, wie es ist, je nachdem.
Ja, da ist noch ein bisschen gespannt drauf.
Tesla kauft Apple.
Mit welchem Geld? Aber gut.
Das finde ich nicht so schlecht.
Dann, so technologisch, was wird da passieren?
Werden wir dann doch endlich den Geruchsfernseher haben?
Hoffentlich nicht. Ich glaube, so zwei Belgier arbeiten da dran als einzige und die machen keinerlei Fortschritte, stellenweise leider Rückschritte auch und kommen nicht voran. Die waren mal weiter, das stimmt. Die waren wirklich schon mal weiter. Ich habe da Aktien gekauft, irgendwie ganz, ganz viele und deswegen ärgert mich das sehr, dass die da nicht vorankommen.
Aber klar, Virtual Reality wird eine riesige Rolle spielen.
Neue Arten von Control-Game-Pads
werden... Wohingegen Augmented Reality
gar keine Rolle. Augmented Reality
wird sterben, wirklich, komplett.
Ja, absolut. Virtual Reality
wird durch die Decke gehen. 3D-Kino
wird komplett aussterben.
Ich glaube eh, das Kino sterben wird weiter vor sich gehen. Streaming-Dienste werden eine grössere Rolle spielen, mehr Filme produzieren. Und Netflix kauft, nee, Amazon kauft Sky. Netflix kauft Watch Ever. Clipfish wird von YouTube gekauft. Endlich. Endlich. Oh mein Gott, da kann ich endlich den ganzen geilen Clipfish-Content auch da sehen. Ja, den würde ich jetzt endlich immer auf C eintippen muss in meinem Browser, ganz, ganz furchtbar. Einer der schwerer zu erreichenden Buchstaben, sehr unangenehm. Gibt es Clipfish noch? Bestimmt. Was passiert da? Ja, keine Ahnung, MySpaar zum Beispiel hat eine Daseinsberichtung einfach für die alten Axel Folgen. Axel Stein irgendwie als Jugendlicher erlebt Abenteuer mit Sami Challah und schaue ich immer mal wieder gerne rein, weil das habe ich als Jugendlicher tatsächlich ganz gerne geguckt, so dieses harte Jungs, knallharte Jungs, Axel Stein Ding. Du bist ja so ein knallharte Junge gewesen. Ich war ein knallharte Junge und natürlich hat, glaube ich, vielen Leuten durch die Pubertät geholfen und natürlich Axelel war auch ein wichtiger, dicker, lustiger Typ, so ein bisschen rebellisch. Das war genau meins. Da habe ich mich natürlich abgefühlt geholt. Ja, du Rebell. Literatur AG im Koa-Kor. Also da habe ich mich wirklich wiedererkannt. Also ja, ich habe Axel geguckt und King of Queens, so immer so dicke, lustige Leute mit hübschen Freundinnen.
Das war so genau meine perfekte Welt.
King of Queens hat mir auch geholfen damals.
Ich dachte, ja okay, jeder kann jeden haben.
Alles ist möglich, es kommt nicht aufs Aussehen an, fand ich auch schön.
Außer du bist eine Frau halt, dann schon.
Aber so kannst du auch dick sein. Außer du bist eine Frau, then you better be good looking, sonst war es das. Das stimmt. Ja, nee, aber war eine irre andere Zeit. War eine irre, wirklich irre andere Zeit. Ich wollte jetzt auch mal noch mal so alte Serien gucken, so was wie Bayblade oder so, einfach um zu verstehen, was da die Handlung ist, was da die Handlung passiert. Das würde mich interessieren. Auch Yu-Gi-Oh! Yu-Gi-Oh! Auch Sailor Moon! Dann auch ein Duell über acht Folgen gestreckt wird. Ja, aber Yu-Gi-Oh! Ich frage mich schon, wie kriegen sie eine Folge mit einem Duell voll? Nein, acht Folgen, ein Duell. Aber Yu-Gi-Oh! Aber Yu-Gi-Oh! hast du zumindest, okay, welche Karte zieht er, Spannung, Spannung, dann kommt die Kreatur, dann siehst du die. Ah, doch nur Joker. Fuck, fuck, fuck. Wir zählen diese Zahlen hoch, das macht Spaß, aber Beyblade so, dann drehen sich. Einer gewinnt im Kreiseln, also auch, wie man das geschafft, ist das eine Wette, hat jemand eine Wette verloren und du musst das Kreiseln wieder berühmt machen und er hat es geschafft. Er hat es tatsächlich geschafft, ich sage euch, vielleicht, genau, ein guter Punkt, eigentlich 2021, vielleicht kommt Jojo, der Jojo kommt zurück. Jojo kommt zurück oder so dieses, wie heißt es, dieses Diabolo, wo man so zwei Stöcke hat und dann irgendwie diese merkwürdige Sanduhr formen. Aber das konnte ich, also das ist das Lustige, ich habe das einmal immer gesehen und fand es insane. Irgendwie in der Fußgängerzone hat das jemand gemacht, hat den ganzer hochgeworfen und gefangen. Ich dachte mir, how the fuck is this possible? Und dann habe ich mir das gekauft und konnte das sofort. Das ist mein einer Skill. Ich konnte es sofort krass beschleunigen, dann hochwerfen und fangen, als wäre es nichts. Also vielleicht kommt das tatsächlich zurück. Also ich sag Diablo, du sagst Jojo, eins von beiden, glaube ich, die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist hoch. Nach dem weirden Fidget-Spinner-Hype, der auch noch nicht, in meinen Augen, noch nicht aufgearbeitet wurde, der kurz schnell rotiert ist und dann wieder weg war, der wurde in meinen Augen, wo ist der Video-Essay zum Phänomen Fidget-Spinner? Warum war das so erfolgreich? Wer hat da viel Geld verdient, wer hat viel Geld verloren? Ich will diesen Video-Essay. Wer hat viel Geld verloren? Du hast viel Geld verloren. Ja, ich weiß. Wo sind die Lagerhallen? Wo sind die Lagerhallen mit den Fidget-Spinnern? Es muss irgendwo im Atlantik ein riesiger Haufen Fidget-Spinner sein, und da will ich jetzt die Meeresbogen. Oder so Tiere, die auf der Schnauze so einen Fidget Spinner haben, die die ganze Zeit drehen. Oder so ein Oktopus, der acht Fidget Spinner gleichzeitig einfach dreht. Und so gemeistert hat. Was hat das für einen Einfluss auf die Tierwelt unter Wasser? Weil da müssen ja Lastwagenladungen einfach versenkt worden sein. Wenn die den Wert so weit verloren haben, wird es einfach versenkt. Aber es ist ruhig geworden in den Meeren, hat man das Gefühl. Es tummelt sich nicht mehr in den Meeren. Man hat nicht mehr von, weil ich glaube, weil die Tiere was zu tun haben. Die haben so, die fidgeten. Stimmt, alle Forscher merken so, dieser Hai, der taucht nicht mehr auf. Schnitt zum Hai. Und dann hat er gleich noch ein Giftgrün.
Oder auch mit so einem Haikopf drauf.
Kann sein, ausser das will ich aufgearbeitet haben. Was passiert? Oder wurden die irgendwie umgearbeitet? Hat Tesla die aufgebaut und die sind jetzt alle, betreiben jetzt die Elektroautos? Fittelspinner sind genauso lang im Kontext der Welt erfolgreich gewesen, wie ich sie, wie ich einen spannend fand, ihn zu benutzen. Genauso, wenn man denkt, ja gut, sie können nur drehen. Und dann hat die ganze Welt gesagt, ah ja, alle im Chor haben gesagt, ah, sie können sich nur drehen. Und dann haben sie das weggeschmissen. Ja, als die gesamte Welt zusammenkam und sich einig war, ja, die können sich nur drehen. Okay, das war's, vielen Dank. Danke, Fidget Spinner. Das waren die Fidget Spinner. Im Prinzip sind wir doch wie so ein, die Welt ist vor so einem grossen Kassenband, wo einfach, wo Guido Kanz hintersteht und so Produkt, ja, und Fidget Spinner sind abgepiept. Ja, Fidget Spby sind abgepiept. Jetzt gucken wir mal. Aber die nächsten kommen schon. Lass uns mal nach links gucken, was ist da alles noch auf dem Fließband. Wo wir stehen. Okay, oder nach unten. Aber jetzt, okay, ich glaube, es kommen erst mal so sieben Kunden Differenzierungsmodule. Erst mal so, da hat einer viel zu viel draufgelegt oder er wollte fünf kaufen. Oder er kauft fünf. Man weiß nicht genau.
Aber ich glaube, dann kommt erst mal der Fitch.
Ich glaube, Diabolo ist, ich glaube, wir haben an jeder Tankstelle so einen Haufen Diabolos.
Jojo-Fights, wo man so gegeneinander schnackt.
Aha.
Oder jeder hat so einen Hutsternartigen Jojos.
So einen Hut auf dem Kopf, wo irgendwas draufliegt
und man muss das mit dem Jojo wegstoßen
vom Handel irgendwie da so. Und schlägt
jemand einfach mit voller Wucht ins Auge
und dann werden wieder viele eingeliefert und
dann gibt es eine bestimmte Krankheit, die dann
so heißen. Ich prophezeie hiermit,
dass gleitende Gegenstände
durch Magnetismus
oder was auch immer. Hovercraft? Hovercraft, hoverboardartige Dinge werden eine Rolle spielen. Gleitende? Gleitende Dinge werden eine Rolle spielen. Ich sage auch nicht wie, aber auch mal so ein Laptop, der so auf dem Tisch gleitet, weil unten drunter in den Magnet eingelassen ist oder so in den Tisch. Dinge, die gleitende Dinge werden eine Rolle spielen.
Mehr sage ich nicht mehr.
Kontaktlos.
Dann gehe ich noch weiter.
Ich sage, kontaktlos wird eine grosse Rolle spielen.
Sei es Handy aufladen ohne Kabel, sei es man muss nicht mehr ein Kabel anschliessen an einen Monitor,
sei es ich muss nicht mehr irgendwo hingehen, um was zu kaufen.
All diese Dinge kontaktlos, wir werden weniger Kontakt haben.
Das ist meine Prophezeiung für 2021.
Genau, einfach an Dinge denken und das Handy macht es.
Ich habe Hunger und das Handy kauft mir was, was ich mir wünsche.
Allein weil es meine Augen verfolgt, wo die hingucken.
Es besorgt mir so Dinge, wenn ich durch die Fussgängerzone gehe.
Also du musst es nur angucken. Stimmt aber eigentlich, oder vielleicht es gibt ja am Ende des Tages so eine Liste wenn ich durch die Fussgängerzone gehe, also wird dann auch gefährlich.
Stimmt aber eigentlich, oder vielleicht, es gibt ja am Ende des Tages
so eine Liste an Dingen, die du angeguckt hast,
und dann kannst du auswählen, welches du kaufst.
Wichtig ist... Du meinst, du kaufst automatisch.
Ja, das wird dann schwierig. Ich glaube, wichtiger wäre,
du hast ja auch ein Apple Watch und schlicht
am Handgelenk, die Dinge,
die du angeguckt hast, wo dein Puls hochgegangen ist,
leicht, die kaufst du direkt.
Sehr gut. Und je nachdem, wie hoch dein Puls war, desto klarer ist der Kauf oder zweimal direkt gekauft. Und wenn es nur ein bisschen war, fragt er dich vielleicht, wollen sie es wirklich kaufen? Wenn der Puls runterging, dann wird es aktiv verkauft. Spannende Idee, finde ich gut. Mal gucken, ob es sich durchsetzt.
Aber Stefan hätte es auf jeden Fall prophezeit.
Sein Jojo leider komplett überhaupt nicht stattgefunden.
Niemann Jojo-Zahlen gehen zurück.
Aber was gut an Prophezeiungen ist, das, was nicht eingetreten ist,
nobody cares.
Was die Simpsons alle für einen Schwachsinn noch vorausgegeben haben.
Ja, ja, klar. Lisa Simpson
wird Präsidentin. Hallo,
Realität. Hallo, hallo, hey, Simpsons hier. Homer Simpson ist auf dem Mond. Wann ist das statt, hat das Stattel gefunden? Nein, ist er nicht. Er ist eine Zeichentriegfigur. Ja. Trottel. Aber da sagt niemand, oh, Boo, Simpson, alle sagen, wow. Schwachsinn. Trump als Präsident, ja. Trump wurde vorhergesehen. Krass. Ja, aber Sorgon und Morgon, dass die aus dem Weltraum kommen, ah, nicht passiert. Ja, Mr Burns hat fliegende Affen mit Flügel hinten am Rücken. Wo sind sie denn? Ja, hallo, sind sie. Fliegen sie zu hoch? Können wir sie nur nicht sehen oder existieren sie nicht? Trottelautor. Voll Idiot. Ja, diese ganzen Simpsons-Fans, wirklich ganz, ganz furchtbar. Deswegen kann man sich, wir können es auch noch weiter aus dem Fenster lehnen, weil es geht nicht darum, was man nicht vorher sieht, sondern was man vorher sieht. Ja. Das ist ein Zitat, mit dem ich in die Brüchte eingehen möchte. Vor allem, oder am Ende wird es halt so Tellerdrehen. Und wir lagen beide falsch. Aber so ganz knapp falsch. Der Tellerdreh-Hype is real. Die jungen Leute in Berlin treffen sich alle, um Teller drehen zu lassen. Jeder YouTube-Star hat irgendwie so einen Tellerdreher.
Ich hatte sowohl einen Jojo, als auch einen Beyblade, als auch Jojo-Karten, als auch einen drehenden Teller, als auch einen Diablo-Lolo. Ich glaube, 2021 wird das Jahr der Streamer. Ich glaube, Streamer übernehmen langfristig die Entertainment-Branche und Streaming-Plattformen werden immer relevanter und Streamen werden sich auch ausweiten. Also nicht nur so Gaming und sowas, sondern auch ganz viel natürlich so Just-Chatting, Real-Life-Sachen, aber auch Einblicke in Berufe. Irgendwie mal eine Operation oder so wird live gestreamt, keine Ahnung, irgendein Promi lässt sich operieren, streamt die Operation live, kann man dann zugucken, was da passiert. Sowas in der Richtung, ich glaube, die Kamera rückt näher an den Menschen und dann glaube ich, dass das wirklich nochmal viel revolutionieren wird. Ich glaube, sowas wie Filme, Serien werden langfristig aussterben. Dieses, ich setze mich jetzt mal eineinhalb Stunden hin und gucke mir das an und dann ist gut.
Weil schon heute haben alle Second Screen, läuft nur noch nebenbei und ich glaube, irgendwann ist das einfach weg und du bist nur noch bei Streams, die einfach konstant Input geben und die Erwartungshaltung wird geringer. So bei einem Streamer erwartest du ja nicht, dass der die ganze Zeit geile Gags raushaut, wie das jetzt irgendwie in Comedian machen würde bei einem Stand-up, sondern du srieselst so nebenbei und ich glaube, irgendwie die Entertainment-Branche wird in sich zusammenfallen wie ein schlecht gebautes Kartenhaus. Wie ein schlecht gebauter Spaghetti-Turm aus diesem Assessment-Center. Spaghetti-Marshmallow-Turm. Ja, genau. Das wollte ich unbedingt machen, als ich es gesehen habe, dachte ich mir, das mache ich jetzt auch. Das wollte ich unbedingt machen. Ich musste das ja quasi inspiriert von meinem eigenen Assessment-Center, wo ich dann so eine Spaghetti-Tour machen muss. Und ich musste auch eine Brücke bauen, nur aus Papier und Klebeband. Eine Brücke bauen. Toll. Oh, ich habe auch entdeckt, ich kenne wahrscheinlich auch schon viele Taskmaster, britische Serie, ganz, ganz simples Konzept irgendwie, so fünf Promis werden eingeladen, die dann halt so Aufgaben erfüllen müssen, wie zum Beispiel so eine Brücke zu bauen. Und es klingt so simpel und dumm und Augenrollen und das habe ich schon tausendmal gesehen, aber die Serie ist so gut gemacht, die Briten können einfach Fernsehen und da sind richtig coole Leute dabei, James Acaster natürlich ist in einer Staffel komplett dabei und so coole Aufgaben, so coole Moderatoren, so cooler Humor, jeder von denen ist lustig, jedes Teammitglied ist lustig, alle sind lustig und es ist fantastisch, ist auch alles auf YouTube verfügbar, Taskmaster, schaut euch das mal an, ihr werdet es nicht bereuen. Genau, wenn ihr schon mal dabei seid, James A. Kester, die drei Stand-Up-Specials, die er rausgehauen hat, vor ein paar Jahren, nach wie vor unglaublich lustig, nicht zum Lautloslachen, aber zum Wahnsinn, weg wowen. Du wirst weg wowed. Was ist das für ein Emoji? Dieser, wo das Gehirn nach oben fliegt. Ah ja, okay. Emoji-Prophezeiung ist natürlich auch noch eine Frage. Was kommt als nächstes? Pokerchip. Ich weiß nicht, seit drei Jahren warten wir auf den Pokerchip, er wird glaube ich nicht kommen. Kartoffelchip? Oder halt das Diabolo, ich weiß nicht, vielleicht kommt das dann. Jetzt drehen wir uns im Kreis oder wir haben den perfekten Abschluss für diese Fidget Spinner-Folge gefunden. Für diese Fidget Spinner-Folge. Wir wünschen euch fantastische Weihnachten. Ihr habt einen fantastischen, also feiert im kleinen Rahmen. Oder gar nicht, ist auch okay. Ich finde gar nicht, man muss gar nicht frohe Weihnachten wünschen, weil wenn ihr dieses Jahr keine frohen Weihnachten habt, ist auch okay.
Dieses Jahr ist halt mal anders. Wir wünschen euch einsame Weihnachten. Wir wünschen euch Weihnachten. Das könnt ihr selber auslegen, wie ihr wollt. Oder alles andere, was ihr feiert, je nachdem, worauf ihr Lust habt. Aber trotzdem kommt gut ins neue Jahr. Es hat so viel Spaß gemacht mit euch.
Vielen Dank für alle, die mitgemacht haben, mitgewirkt haben,
hinter den Kulissen an unserem 80-Köffpers Redaktionsteam und natürlich an euch, liebe Podcast-Officer-Community. Vielen Dank für die ganzen Intros, die wir bekommen haben, grandiosen Sachen dabei, für die Antenne-Afrika-Beiträge, für die tollen Projekte der Telegram-Gruppe, jetzt mit dem Adventskalender natürlich den Höhepunkt gefunden, ganz, ganz viele tolle Sachen, tolle Community, die wir haben. Ohne euch wäre das alles nur halb so lustig. Und deswegen freue ich mich wahnsinnig auf 2021. Wir haben einiges vor. Oh ja. Wir können auf jeden Fall, glaube ich, uns total freuen, alle gemeinsam auf das Podcast-Sofia 2021. Und wir wünschen euch Weihnachten und Silvester, wünsche ich euch auch.
Macht's gut.
Und wir heben ein letztes Mal ab.
Zu weist Bubble Night.